some fans never thought it happened but
a few never lost faith so what's the
biggest Soca Cameo that's got everyone
weeping into their blue milk this is
where the fun begins we're halfway
through Ahsoka and episode 4 ends with
the biggest Twist of the show so far if
you paid any attention to the trailers
or pre-release coverage you probably
expected Hayden christensen's Anakin
Skywalker to pop up at some point but
Fallen Jedi brings him face to face with
his old Padawan in a huge way so how did
we get here and what does that all mean
after crash landing on cetos Ahsoka
Sabine and who Yang continue their
mission to stop Morgan elsbeth from
locating Grand Admiral thrawn with her
massive hyperspace ring completed and
the Magical map to thrawn's location in
the neighboring Galaxy open Morgan seems
all set to bring the chess strategist
back and start the war all over again
while the map hones in on the final
coordinates for the journey Ahsoka and
sabineka to swathe through Morgan's
forces Ahsoka makes short work of the
mysterious marak and Dolls Balin skull
for the map while Sabine faces off
against Shin horti in the end Baylin
knocks Ahsoka off a cliff and convinces
Sabine to surrender the map the whole
group launches into hyperspace except
for Ahsoka who awakens in a mysterious
ethereal place and then she hears two
little words that only one man would
ever say
low snips
we don't see what happens to us so
crafter Baylin knocks her into the sea
what we do know is where she winds up in
this sort of the most likely explanation
is that Ahsoka has fallen into the world
Between Worlds a Mystical Force realm
outside of time and space that she
briefly visited in Star Wars Rebels
perhaps the magic on cetos opened a
gateway to the dimension just like how
Ezra opened one to save Ahsoka from
Darth Vader in Rebels or maybe her
arrival there is true divine
intervention some kind of cosmic
correction to keep her on her path
regardless Anakin's involvement in the
scene marks an important moment in Star
Wars history christensen's version of
the character has never interacted with
Ahsoka before as she doesn't appear in
any of the Star Wars pre-course however
their relationship has become one of the
defining features of Anakin's character
their reunion no doubt makes for a
powerful moment for longtime fans
especially given that's the last time
they met in Canon they were fighting to
the death I won't leave
not this
no what does the world Between Worlds
mean for the second half of Ahsoka well
all for one thing it presents an
opportunity for Ahsoka and Anakin to
reconcile it's possible that Anakin has
some deeper knowledge of what's going on
in the cosmos I could help Ahsoka stop
thrawn more likely though he'll help her
navigate some of her personal baggage to
reconnect with herself and the force
since Rosario Dawson started playing the
character in The Mandalorian season two
ahsokas felt much more closed off and
stoic that makes some sense given all
that she's been through but it's
possible that Anakin can help her find
her balance once more if Ahsoka is in
the world Between Worlds she might also
be able to hop on a shortcut to where
Sabine Baylin Morgan and the others are
all going there's no reason to think the
force realm couldn't stretch across
multiple galaxies and since it allows us
residents to travel through time she
could even get there before Morgan's
hyperspace Ring Of course that would
require Ahsoka to control the magic
within the dimension something that's
easier said than done the truth is very
little has ever been revealed about the
world Between Worlds that means that
Dave filoni and the creative team of
Ahsoka could use their for any number of
reasons it also makes the next four
episodes kinda difficult to predict one
thing's for sure though Sabine and the
rest of the Galaxy are in real danger if
thrawn begins as return to power bailin
has also alluded to some larger
implications of the grand Amaral's
return which given his Jedi training
could be Force related to be honest
though most fans probably aren't
thinking too hard about what comes next
the mere promise of Anakin and Ahsoka
catching up in live action is enough to
keep excitement High while we wait for
episode 5. let's just hope that the
Cameo is genuine and not some trick of
the dark side after all in Star Wars
it's sometimes hard to know what's real